نعم تحيه لكم ومشاهدي قناه الجزيره بدايه
دعيني ابدا بعجله العتاد التي تم تفجيرها
بالامس طبعا حقيقه في في مثل هذه الظروف
وفي مثل هذه الحروب دائما لا يتم الاعلان
على مثل هذه الحوادث لان هذه القضيه تمس
بسمعه الجيش وبادا القتالي وبالتالي يتم
التكتم عليها بشكل كبير جدا ويتم معالجه
الموقف يعني داخليا لا ان يكون هناك اعلان
عن طريق الاعلام وما تم كما تم الان يعني
ولكن اعلان الجيش الصهيوني اذا ما سلمنا
بهذه الروايه فهذا يعطي دلاله واضحه على
انه هناك عدم تنسيق هناك عدم تبادل
معلومات هناك ارتبات ارتباك في القطعات
التي تعمل في هذه المنطقه ولذلك حدث مثل
هذا الخطا الجسيم الذي يقول عنه الجيش
الصهيوني واذا ما اردنا ان نذهب ابعد الى
هذا نقول بان هذه الحوادث قد تكررت عده
مرات خلال هذه الفت فتره وهذا يعطي دلاله
على ان هناك شيء خلف الاكمه يريدون الوصول
اليه من خلال هذه الاعلانات لان يريدون ان
يقولون بان الجيش الصهيوني تعرض الى اخطاء
وقتل جنوده في الميدان وبالتالي قتل
المدنيين يمكن ان يكون مبرر في مثل هذه
الحروق انا اعتقد بان كثره الاعلان عنها
هذه الحوادث يعني له ما له ما له في هذا
الامر فلذلك يتم الاعلان عنها به بهذه
الصوره يضاف الى ذ اذا جئنا الى اذا اذا
لم نسلم بالروايه الصهيونيه في مساله
التفجير نقول بانه فصائل المقاومه اثناء
المعركه او اثناء الاشتباك تم سقوط قنبله
على هذه العجله وتم تفجيرها او ان دائما
العتاد يكون فيه احتكاك داخلي وهذا
الاحتكاك يمكن ان يؤدي الى انفجار مثل هذه
العجلات التي تحمل هذه الكميات الكبيره من
الاعتدا لذلك يمكن ان يكون التبرير بهذه
الطريقه اما ان يكون بانه قذيفه قذيفه
دبابه اطلقت وهذه القذيفه تسببت في تفجير
هذه العجله فانا اعتقد فيها علامه استفهام
كبيره جدا يضاف الى ذلك بان عمليه الكمين
التي نفذت حقيقه الكمائن دائما اما ان
تكون كمائن مدبره او تكون كمائن مستعجله
او اما ان يكون الكمين اما كمين خطي او
كمين منطقه وبالتالي عندما ناتي الى هذا
الكمين الذي ينفذ من قبل كتائب القسام نجد
بانه يحتمل النوعين سواء كان كمين خطي او
كمين مدبر او كمين مستعجل او كمين كمين
المنطقه وبالتالي الكمين يتكون من ثلاثه
مجموعات المصد الايمن والمصد الايسر
ومجموعه القتل ومجموعه الستر التي تؤمن
انسحاب الكمين الى الخلف وهذا يعني بان
هذه السياقات هي السياقات النظاميه في
الحرب النظاميه وفي الجيوش النظاميه التي
تتبع لغرض المواجهه في استخدام تعبئه
الكمائن لغرض ايقاع اكبر ما يمكن من
الخسائر وهذا يعني بان فصائل المقاومه
تمزج ما بين الحرب النظاميه وما بين حرب
العصابات طيب و ب فقط اقى معي سيد فلاح
لكي انو الى خبر العاجل على ارض المان هذا
الخبر العاجل عن مراسلنا شهيد وخمسه جرحى
في قصف اسرائيلي استهدف سياره قرب ملعب
فلسطين بحي الرمال في غزه يعني السيد
فلاحي بغض النظر عن ملابسات هذه الحادثه
والاسباب الحقيقيه وراء الاعلان عنها وقد
حظيت بجدل ربما لا يضاهيه سوى الجدل الذي
حضيت به حادثه قتل ثلاثه اسر بالخطا كما
تقول اسرائيل كيف يؤثر على معنويات هذا
الجيش الذي اصلا يتعرض لحمله داخليه في
اسرائيل نعم لا شك بان هذه تؤثر على على
على اداء المقاتلين وعلى نفسيه المقاتلين
بشكل كبير جدا لذلك اقول بان مثل هذه
الحوادث لا يتم الاعلان عنها خصوصا وان
الجيش يقتل افراده يعني يعني هذه القضيه
يمكن ان تثير عليهم الكثير من المسائل
داخليا لكن يبدو بان التبرير الذي يريدون
ان يصلون اليه بانه الجيش يمكن ان تحدث
فيه اخطاء وان قتل المدنيين قد يكون مبرر
بالنسبه للجيش الصهيوني في مثل هذه الحرب
خصوصا وانه الان يجب على اسرائيل ان تمثل
امام محكمه العدل الدوليه خلال هذه الايام
عن الاباده الجماعيه التي نفذت في غزه
طوال هذه الحرب التي استمرت اكثر من 96
يوم لذلك هو يحاول ان يجد مبررات متعدده
في هذا الامر ويحاول الان ان ان ان يظهر
هذه الاخطاء الى الى الى العلن خصوصا وان
هذه القضيه تمس بسمعه الجيش تمس بالحاله
المعنويه والنفسيه للمقاتل ولكن مع هذا
هناك اصرار على اظهار مثل هذه الحوادث
واعلانها من خلال الاعلان لذلك انا ارى
بان هذه الحوادث تؤثر نعم ولكن هذه
الاخطاء لا يمكن ان ترتكب بهذه الكميه
خلال هذه الحرب وخلال هذه المده الوجيزه
شكرا لك ضيفنا من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي m